wir schauen auf den nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt an diesem Freitag an
diesem letzten Tag dieser Sitzungswoche
nächste Woche geht's ja übrigens direkt
weiter hier im Deutschen Bundestag es
geht um den Kinder und jugendbericht der
Bundesregierung der ist schon im
November 2020 vorgelegt worden jetzt
wird der diskutiert Schwerpunkt ist in
diesem mal die in diesem Jahr bzw in
diesem Bericht es ist der 16 insgesamt
die Förderung demokratischer Bildung
Grund für den Höhen höheren Bedarf so
sagen die Autoren der Studie sein die
Herausforderung durch Globalisierung und
Klimawandel sowie die Gefährdung der
Demokratie durch Populismus und
Extremismus mit den Kindern und
Jugendliche schon relativ früh
konfrontiert würden das also jetzt
gleich Thema in der sich anschließenden
Debatte wir sehen noch ein wenig in die
Rotation hier rein im Bundestag die
Fachpolitiker wechseln naturgemäß bei
den verschiedenen Tagesordnungspunkten
Wolfgang Kubicki noch recht geduldig wir
sehen auch Lisa Paus die zuständige
Ministerin ist da steht auf und geht zum
Pult und dann geht es jetzt auch los
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen liebe
zuhörende der 16 Kinder und
jugendbericht zeigt die politische
Bildung junger Menschen ist ein
Stützpfeiler unserer Demokratie und sie
ist heute wichtiger denn je denn sieben
große Megatrends fordern die Demokratie
besonders heraus
Klimakrise und Pandemie Globalisierung
Digitalisierung demografischer Wandel
Migration Erstarken der Nationalismus
und natürlich aktuell sogar ein Krieg in
Europa
das alles beeinflusst auch das
Aufwachsen junger Menschen gerade in
diesen Zeiten kommt deshalb politischer
Bildung eine große Verantwortung zu
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
demokratie braucht DemokratInnen und
Demokraten und politische Bildung hat
den Auftrag junge Menschen zu Demokratie
zu befähigen Demokratie ist nichts was
man in der Schule lernt wie Vokabeln
oder vielleicht wie Binomische
Gleichungen sondern Demokratie lebt
davon dass wir sie jeden Tag miteinander
leben
und deshalb deshalb ist die wichtigste
Botschaft dieses Berichtes politische
Bildung gehört überall hin sie gehört in
die Familie in die Kita in die Schule in
die Ausbildung in Jugendbildungsstätten
oder in Jugendverbände alle Kinder und
Jugendliche haben einen Recht auf
politische Bildung meine Damen und
Herren
und politische Bildung dauert im Grunde
ein Leben lang in der Jugendarbeit beim
gesellschaftlichen Engagement in
Vereinen in der Bundeswehr in den Medien
und immer geht es um die klassischen
fragen wie funktioniert unsere
Gesellschaft wie kommen wir zu
gemeinsamen Entscheidungen und wie
verabreden wir Regeln an die sich auch
alle halten
das Ziel politischer Bildung ist aber
auch ganz konkret sich begegnen auf
Augenhöhe und mit Respekt zu lernen sich
eine eigene Meinung zu bilden aber eben
auch mit unterschiedlichen Meinungen
umzugehen und sie zu tolerieren und hier
wird auch außerhalb der Schule viel
geleistet das fördert mein
bundesjugendministerium sehr umfänglich
mit dem Kinder- und jugendplan und mit
Programmen wie Jugend der erinnert und
dem respekt-coaches und auch mit dem
großen wichtigen Programm Demokratie
leben
[Applaus]
aber Demokratie Förderung ist eine
Daueraufgabe und deshalb werde ich
zusammen mit Nancy fazer das
demokratie-fördergesetz Einbringen meine
Damen und Herren
werte Abgeordnete Werte zuhörende ich
will auch dass 16-Jährige wählen können
in diesem Land
und ich will dass Kinderrechte im
Grundgesetz endlich verankert werden
der Bericht plädiert übrigens ebenfalls
für beides und die Bundesregierung hat
beides in Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
und ich persönlich werde da definitiv
nicht locker lassen
eine weitere Diagnose des Berichtes
lautes politische Bildung wirkt umso
nachhaltiger wenn sie mit handfestem
demokratischen Erfahrungen einhergeht
wenn eben Demokratie gelebt wird wer
früh mitentscheiden darf und erlebt dass
die eigene Meinung zählt dass man sich
auf demokratische Prozesse verlassen
kann der hat gute Chancen auch dann an
wirklich ein Demokratie Fan zu werden
und auch darum setzen wir den Nationalen
Aktionsplan für mehr Kinder und
Jugendbeteiligung auf meine Damen und
Herren
und wir stärken die politische Bildung
um Flagge zu zeigen um zu vermitteln
warum Gleichheit warum Pluralismus warum
Menschenrechte Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Gewaltenteilung und Minderheitenschutz
so wichtig sind denn es geht um nichts
anderes als um den unintergehbaren Kern
der Demokratie auch so nennt ihn der
Bericht
und weil der zwischen ganz viele
Zwischenrufe waren und bei ausgerechnet
die die es darauf anlegen die Demokratie
zu hintergehen behaupten politische
Bildung müsse neutral sein sage ich
ihnen eins politische Bildung ist
niemals neutral
politische Bildung ist demokratische
Bildung und deshalb wird sie eben
niemals neutral sein Gegenüber
Demokratie Feinden
politische Bildung ist auch deswegen so
wichtig weil sie macht junge und eben
übrigens auch alte Menschen resilient
dagegen
verschwörungserzählungen und rechten
Parolen auf dem Land zu gehen und
deswegen müssen wir Sie unterstützen ist
sie so wichtig ich danke der Kommission
für diesen wirklich wertvollen Bericht
meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin
[Applaus]
Frau Kollegin fester sie werden sich
jetzt mit einer Minute begnügen müssen
bedauerlicherweise aber so ist das
vorgesehen der nächste Redner ist der
Kollege Ralf Edelhäuser cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerinnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute über den 16 Kinder und
jugendbericht ein Bericht der zu einer
zeitverfasst worden ist und zwar im
September 2018 bis 2020 im Juli in dem
die corona-pandemie ja noch gar nicht in
vollem Umfang abschätzbar waren und
welche Folgen das sie hat und eigentlich
sind ja die entsprechenden gravierten
Einschnitte für unsere Jugendlichen und
Kinder erst danach entstanden wir alle
wissen das was damit zu tun hat es waren
die Schulschließungen es war der
wechselunterricht es war auch die
ungenügende Ausstattung von
Lernplattformen allen teilen und diese
negativen Auswirkungen die hier die
jungen Menschen und die junge Generation
leiden musste hat natürlich auch was zu
tun dass sie mergelnde Bereiche
Kompetenzentwicklung und kognitive
Erfahrungen gesammelt hat und hier ist
es an uns allen aber auch an allen
politischen Ebenen bis zur Kommune
runter dass wir das ausgleichen müssen
in den nächsten Jahren denn das
Vertrauen in die Politik hat den letzten
Jahren gelitten auch das von
Politikerinnen und Politikern und die
Jugendlichen die massive Einschnitte
erfahren mussten in ihre persönlichen
Freiheit zum Beispiel in den
Freizeitverhalten es war kein
Freizeitverhalten möglich was macht der
Jugendlicher Jugendlicher wir sie
treffen wird zusammen sein mit
Gleichaltrigen Fehlanzeige das haben sie
alles ausgehalten aber doch wir haben
großartige Jugendliche weil sie wollen
demokratisch handeln sie wollen junge
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger in unserem
Land sein und dafür einmal herzliches
Dankeschön an die Jugend unseres Landes
nun gilt es aber auch den Jugendlichen
etwas zurückzugeben und da gibt diese 16
Kinder und jugendbericht auch
entsprechende Empfehlungen ab was genau
gemacht werden sollte damit unsere
Jugendlichen auch von unserer Demokratie
partizipieren und sich auch aktiv
einbringen können und wie wahrscheinlich
die meisten von ihnen führe ich auch
regelmäßig Gespräche mit unseren jungen
und sie geben natürlich eindeutig zu
verstehen dass sie eine Zukunft ohne die
Jugendlichen nicht geben kann sie wollen
aktiv mitmachen sie wollen aktiv diese
Zukunft gestalten und eine Möglichkeit
dazu sind die Freiwilligendienste und
deswegen werbe ich hier auch an dieser
Stelle für das freiwillige soziale ja
oder buftis im sozialen Bereich im
ökologischen Bereich
internationales ja egal was hier heißt
für die Jugend dass es sich mit Arbeit
und Leben entsprechend koordinieren
können da lernen Sie was es heißt aktive
Mitsprache kritisches Denken auch
aktives gestalten und wir haben erst in
dieser Woche ein Fach ihr habt da kommt
man das live erleben im
unterausschussbürgerschaftliches
Engagement und es grandios das ist super
und das ist wünschenswert wenn das
natürlich am Ende des Tages auch im
Bundeshaushalt des nächsten Jahres im
Bereich der Freiwilligendienste
wiederheil finden würde zum Beispiel in
einer Erhöhung der entsprechenden
Stellen weil hunderttausende Stellen
gibt es und etwa 300.000 Nachfrage und
jetzt stellen wir uns einmal vor das
Delta kann ja jeder ausrechnen aber was
das für eine Stadt bedeutet Kassel hat
200.000 Einwohner dieses Potenzial wird
nicht genutzt und das Potenzial müssen
wir als Land doch einfach nutzen das
dürfen wir noch nicht liegen lassen auf
der Straße
denn diese Freiwilligendienstler sind
unsere Retter in der Not wenn es geht in
den Kitas in den Schulen in den Horten
in den Seniorenheimen oder in den
öffentlichen Bereichen hinein und
deswegen wie auch im Bericht angemerkt
ist es auch wichtig dass Menschen junge
Menschen die jetzt finanziell nicht so
gut ausgestattet sind im in der Familie
das auch die die Möglichkeit haben
solche Freiwilligendienste annehmen zu
können und hier müssen wir dringend
nachbessern hier müsste das ganze Breite
aufgestellt werden die aktuelle Zeit in
der die Jugendlichen heranwachsen ist es
schwierige Zeit wir wissen es alle
Corona ist noch nicht ganz vorbei die
Angst vor Armut die Inflation des
Kriegsgeschehen die Energiekrise das
sind auch Herausforderungen für die
jungen Menschen im psychischer und
physischer Hinsicht und deswegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist in
unserer Verantwortung dass wir da ein
stabilen Rahmen geben der sie sich
entfalten können und auch politische
Verantwortung übernehmen können das
klingt wieder gut ist es auch
finanziellen Dank
Ralf Edelhäuser CSU Landesgruppe hat er
noch mal Glück gehabt und ist um eine
unmahnung rumgekommen aber sie haben
vielleicht im Hintergrund gehört dass
Wolfgang Kubicki der Bundeshaus
Vizepräsidentin gelegentlich auf sein
Mikrofon klopft wenn er wünscht dass die
Redner oder Rednerinnen ihren Beitrag
beenden jetzt ist der Pult Ulrike Bahr
SPD-Fraktion und Vorsitzende im
Familienausschuss des Bundestages
zu diese Rückmeldung bekam ich am
vergangenen Montag von einer
Teilnehmerin des Herings Heimerziehung
Herr Kollege Edelhäuser war auch dabei
mit dem hearing konnten wir im
Familienausschuss jungen Menschen die in
Einrichtungen der Jugendhilfe aufwachsen
oder aufgewachsen sind die Möglichkeit
bieten sich direkt an die Politik zu
wenden
im Workshops hatten sie sich akribisch
und ausführlich darauf vorbereitet das
ist für mich geliebte Jugendpolitik den
politische Bildung darf nicht Theorie
bleiben sie braucht unbedingt auch
politische Beteiligung und
Selbstvertretung und Aufgabe der Politik
ihre Aufgabe ist es dafür die Räume zu
Ende
der 16 Kinder und jugendbericht stellt
diesen direkten Bezug zwischen
politischer Bildung und Beteiligung sehr
klar und deutlich fest politische
Bildung vermittelt nicht nur wissen sie
soll Demokratie praktisch erfahrbar
machen damit ermöglicht sie dass sich
Jugendliche aktiv und gestaltend an
Politik beteiligen politische Bildung
befähigt Kinder und Jugendliche sich
entsprechend ihre Interessen politisch
zu informieren und sich eine Meinung zu
bilden sie lädt ein zum einmischen und
mitmischen sie schult im kritischen
Umgang mit Medien das muss regelmäßig
geübt und angewendet werden und findet
natürlich nicht nur in der Schule statt
sondern immer in der Familie an
außenschulischen Orten und in
Jugendorganisationen
nach der letzten nach der letzten Reform
des Kinder- und jugendhilfe-rechts haben
selbstvertretungsorganisationen nun
einen Anspruch darauf einbezogen und
gefördert zu werden und ich bin davon
überzeugt dass das die Bereitschaft zum
Engagement erhöht Anspruch auf
Beteiligung Förderung und
Selbstvertretung sollten übrigens auch
die Eltern erhalten und nutzen
liebe Kollegen Kollegen mir ist es
wichtig hier und heute auf die zu
schauen die normalerweise nicht im Fokus
von Jugendverbandsarbeit und politischer
Bildung stehen in der Kinder- und
Jugendhilfe ist die sogenannte
kehrlieferbewegung in den letzten Jahren
immer stärker geworden junge Menschen
die im Heim groß geworden sind standen
lange am Rand der Gesellschaft nun haben
sie gezeigt welche Kraft sie entfalten
können wenn sie als Gesprächspartner
ernst genommen werden Raum bekommen und
konsequent beteiligt werden die
Erfahrung der eigenen Kompetenz der
Selbstwirksamkeit ist das beste Mittel
gegen Politikverdrossenheit und für eine
lebendige Demokratie
und da sind alle gefordert die
Verantwortung tragen ob in Schule
Jugendhilfe oder auf den verschiedenen
politischen Ebenen denn Diskussionen mit
jungen Menschen sind oft anstrengend und
das ist auch gut so wer sonst sollte ein
Recht auf radikale Ansichten auf
Maximalforderungen auf lautstarken
Protest haben solange das gewaltfrei und
im persönlichen Grund Respekt
voreinander geschieht ist das völlig in
Ordnung und sogar notwendig
für die Politik gilt dass die eigene
Bequemlichkeit und das Beibehalten
geordneter Abläufe keine guten Gründe
sind um jungen Menschen Beteiligung zu
verwehren
mit dem Nationalen Aktionsplan Kinder
und Jugendbeteiligung schreibt die
Bundesregierung ihre jugendstrategie
deutlich in diese Richtung Fort Ziel des
Plans ist es dass überall Räume
entstehen die echte Mitwirkung möglich
machen meine Meinung nach so sollten wir
diese Beteiligungsrechte auch zügig in
unserer Verfassung verankern
Kinderrechte gehören ins Grundgesetz
denn junge Menschen haben das Recht auf
Schutz auf Bildung und Förderung und auf
Beteiligung und mitsprachigen allem was
sie betrifft ich bitte darum die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
ihre bisherigen Positionen zu
Kinderrechten noch einmal zu überdenken
Demokratie lebt vom Beteiligung machen
wir die Türen auf ich danke Ihnen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin da wir gerade
bei politischer Bildung sind
möchte ich etwas sagen bei der Kollege
Brandner sicher mich gewandt hat mit dem
empfindenden
nachteiligt worden es ging um eine
Kurzintervention und zwei
Zwischenfragen die Kurzintervention habe
ich deshalb nicht zugelassen weil der
nachfolgende Redner aus der afd-fraktion
kam und wir eine redezeitverlängerung
nicht auf diese Art und Weise bewirken
könnten der nachfolgende Redner hätte
eingehen können auf dass das vorher
gesagt worden ist dass der CDU-Fraktion
muss gestern bei meinen Sitzland auch
passiert dass ich eine Vision nicht
zugelassen habe eine Zwischenfrage
zuzulassen wenn der reden da bereits
erklärt hat dass er Zwischenfragen da
die Freizeit grundsätzlich nicht
zulassen will macht keinen Sinn und eine
Zwischenfrage zuzuleiten wenn die
zuzulassen wenn die Redezeit bereits
abgelaufen ist also wir uns in der
Verlängerung befinden macht auch keinen
Sinn deshalb wie gesagt ist das keine
Benachteiligung der afd-fraktion sondern
entspricht der allgemeinen Geschäftslage
nächster Redner der afd-fraktion ist der
Kollege gereon Bollmann
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
der 16 jugendbericht ist ja schon ein
bisschen angegraut aber in zwei Punkten
von dringender Aktualität zum einen
befasst er sich unter Megatrends mit
Islamismus dort heißt es der
Verfassungsschutz zähle rund 26.000 hier
bei uns ansässige Personen zum
islamistisch terroristischen Potenzial
die Islamisten Stimmen im Widerspruch zu
den Grundsätzen der Volkssouveränität
der Trennung von Staat und Religion der
freien Meinungsäußerung und der
allgemeinen Gleichberechtigung
zugleich wird betont es sei zwar unter
Jugendlichen nach islamistischen
Einstellungen zu fragen die
diesbezüglich im Befunde sein aber
aktuell erstaunlich rar und die
gegenwärtigen Erkenntnisse zu diesem
Phänomen nehmen sich noch recht dürftig
aus nun einerseits islamistische Gefahr
gegenwärtiger forschungszustand
defizitär das ruft doch gerade zu nach
Befassung mit dem Thema nach Studien
nach Expertengremien was aber macht die
Bundesregierung
die Kollegin von Frau Pauli
Innenministerin die löscht den
Expertenkreis politischer Islamismus
einfach auf
Verzeihung voraus keine böse Absicht
Kopf in den Sand
statt Schutz der Jugendlichen das ist
die Reaktion und die Folge
der islamismusexpertin die
islamismusexperten Rebecca Schönbach
Vorsitzende des Vereins Frauen für
Freiheit meint hier zu neben Frauen
würden wohl in rabegruppen wie
Jugendliche den Islamisten überlassen
die versuchen werden möglichst viele zu
radikalisieren
also das meine Damen und Herren ist
regierungskunst nach Art der Ampel
als zweiten Aspekt möchte ich ihren
Blick auf den sogenannten
dreidimensionalen Demokratiebegriff
richten dem sich die
Sachverständigenkommission angeschlossen
hat es sind dies die formale die
prozesshafte und die substanzielle
Dimension darunter versteht man den
unhintergehbaren Kern der Demokratie
die fundamentalen Prinzipien wie
Gleichheitsprinzip Pluralismus
Menschenrechte Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Gewaltenteilung und Minderheitenschutz
also die Kernwerte unserer Verfassung es
geht dabei um ein ganz wesentlichen
Gesichtspunkt bei allen Bemühen um
Konsens bei aller Leidenschaft am
Diskurs wird in einer Demokratie am Ende
abgestimmt es gibt Gewinner und
Verlierer wer verloren hat kann aus dem
Gemeinwesen aussteigen oder weiter
mitmachen die Aussteiger immigrieren
oder reagieren laut und der Protest
manchmal mit Gewalt auf letzteres
antwortet die Regierung dann autoritär
mit Depressionen der Unterlegene kann
sich aber auch entscheiden die
Mehrheitsmeinung mitzutragen
dies wird aber nur gelingen wenn diese
nicht allzu weit weg von seinen eigenen
Normen entfernt ist
eine solche mehrheitslösung kann nach
dem bekannten englischen Philosophen und
Vordenker der Aufklärung John Lock in
seinem Werk zwei Abhandlungen über die
Regierung nur und der folgenden
Voraussetzungen gelingen
das Vorhandensein eine öffentlichen
Kultur die Existenz eines Fundamentes an
vor politischer Bürgergemeinschaft und
lebenspraktisch verankerte politisch
kultureller Homogenität des
gesellschaftskörpers
heute würden wir wohl von gemeinsamen
Werten sprechen oder eben auch von einer
Leitkultur eine solche Leitkultur meine
Damen und Herren muss den Jugendlichen
jeglicher Herkunft vermittelt werden
ansonsten droht unsere Demokratie zu
scheitern
lassen Sie mich hinzufügen auch
auch der Regierung sollten diese
Grundwerte dringend nachgeholt werden
auch der Regierung auch der Ampel die
anfängeübergriffigen und autoritären
regierungshandels durften wir ja bereits
in der corona-pandemie erfahren vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
[Applaus]
nachfolgende Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Katja Adler FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als der Bericht
am 11 November 2020 veröffentlicht wurde
hieß die Bundesfamilienministerin noch
Franziska Giffey und die Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel und Deutschland befand
sich zwischen dem ersten und dem zweiten
Lockdown inmitten einer nahezu alles auf
den Kopf stellenden corona-pandemie eine
Zeit in der Schul- und kita-schließung
des Tanzunterricht Fernstudium oder die
ein Freund Vorgabe das Leben von Kindern
und Jugendlichen bestimmte wenig
überraschend wird in dem 16 Kinder und
jugendbericht diese prägende
corona-krise für die 13,5 Millionen
Kinder und Jugendlichen in unserem Land
als Stresstest für die offene
demokratische Gesellschaft bezeichnet
nun knapp zwei Jahre später befinden
sich diese Kinder und Jugendlichen in
einer gesellschaftlichen und politischen
Situation wieder die wir als multiple
Krisensituation bezeichnen können mit
einer nicht enden wollenden
corona-pandemie dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine der
Energiekrise der Inflation und der
Drohnen Rezession befindet sich nicht
nur Deutschland in einer umfassenden
Zeitenwende und mittendrin unsere Kinder
und Jugendlichen in Kontext dieser mega
Krisen wird einmal mehr deutlich dass
Demokratie und demokratisches Verhalten
nicht automatisch passieren dies muss
von jeder neuen Generation neu gelernt
und eingeübt werden
kritisch sein Prozesse Entscheidung und
Gegebenheiten hinterfragen Verbündete
finden Mehrheiten bilden für etwas
einstehen sich beteiligen das alles ist
Demokratie dafür braucht es Kenntnis
Kenntnis über unser demokratisches
freiheitliches politisches System über
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten Kenntnis aber
auch über die Gefahren für unsere
Demokratie es braucht politische Bildung
dies zu vermitteln ist unsere
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgaben
wie oft hört man was die da oben in
ihrem Elfenbeinturm in Berlin
entscheiden das kann ich doch eh nicht
beeinflussen es ist unsere Aufgabe diese
Annahme zu widerlegen und gleichzeitig
über Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten zu
informieren politische Bildung findet in
ganz vielen und ganz unterschiedlichen
Lebensräumen statt 94% der drei bis
fünfjährigen und jedes dritte Kind unter
drei Jahren ist in einer
Kindertageseinrichtung betreut positiv
ist dass 12 von 16 Bundesländern in
ihren Bildungsplänen demokratiebildung
als wichtigen aspektpädagogischer
Bildungsarbeit in Kitas verankert haben
politische Bildung findet natürlich auch
in Schulen statt und natürlich liegt
ihre Ausgestaltung dann auch in der
Zuständigkeit der Länder diese Länder
Kompetenz führt das zeigt der Bericht
auch auf auch auf der politischen
bildungsebene zu Unterschieden in der
Qualität und Quantität unter den Ländern
und leider auch unter den einzelnen
Schulformen wie großartig ist es zu
sehen dass nun endlich auch wieder
Schulklassen hier auf dem
besuchertribünen Platz nehmen jeder
Jugendliche sollte bis zu seinem
Schulabschluss oder seinem 18 Geburtstag
die Möglichkeit bekommen wenigstens
einmal in Berlin gewesen zu sein und den
Deutschen Bundestag als das Herz unserer
demokratischen Entscheidungen besucht zu
haben
[Applaus]
politische Bildung passiert aber auch
außerhalb der institutionellen
Bildungseinrichtungen dies müssen wir
verstehen und lenken soziale Netzwerke
werden heute von nahezu allen Kindern
und Jugendlichen auch als ein Instrument
Ihrer Information genutzt 80% der Kinder
und Jugendlichen zwischen 12 und 18
Jahren nutzen Youtube mehrmals am Tag
50% nutzen tiktok oder Instagram und
auch hier werden politische Inhalte
vermittelt mittlerweile selbst von
influencerinnen und influencern sie und
auch Erklärvideos Infokarten Reals
machen heute Meinung umso wichtiger ist
es dass wir eine unabhängige
Medienstruktur haben dass wir sie
stärken denn Medien müssen neutral und
weltoffen sein um eine eigene
Meinungsbildung zu ermöglichen
Kinder und Jugendliche politisch zu
bilden bedeutet auch sie für die
Gefahren für unsere freiheitlich
Demokratie zu sensibilisieren denn neben
dem Thema sexualisiert Gewalt folgt auf
Platz zwei der Gefahren für Kinder und
Jugendliche schon der politische
Extremismus hier müssen wir sowohl auf
den rechts aber auch auf die
Linksextremismus achten
die angesprochenen Risiken haben wir in
den fortschrittskoalition erkannt und
auch als konkrete handlungsaufgabe
angenommen die von der Koalition
erarbeitete jugendstrategie wird alle
Ressorts mit einbinden und über 160
Maßnahmen in neuen Handlungsfeldern
bündeln ein guter Auftakt auch als
Dialog mit den Ländern mit den Kommunen
der Zivilgesellschaft und den jungen
Menschen war die bundesjugendkonferenz
Anfang September und ich lade alle
Jugendlichen ein sich hier diese
Möglichkeit zu nutzen und sich zu
beteiligen herzlichen Dank vielen Dank
Katja Adler war das für die FDP-Fraktion
in dieser Debatte über den Kinder- und
jugendbericht der Bundesregierung und
auch Katja Adler wie viele Rednerinnen
und Redner vor ihr hat genau das
richtige Publikum nämlich junge Menschen
die diese Debatte hier verfolgen
gelegentlich sagen wir sie mit dem Kopf
schütteln Heidi Reicheneck ist am Pult
für die Linksfraktion sie ist unter
anderem Sprecherin für Kinder und
Jugendpolitik
denn er zeig
t um warum Kinder und Jugendbeteiligung
wichtig ist und wie sie erreicht werden
kann die Bundesregierung stimmt in ihrer
Stellungnahme auch bei allem zu und
macht dann deshalb exakt mal wieder
nichts also ich will sie jetzt da auch
nicht in falsches Licht stellen sie
machen nicht nichts sie kürzen den
gesamten Bereich der Kinder- und
Jugendpolitik um 400 Millionen Euro das
sind 40 Prozent im Kinder- und
jugendland steht ein Minus von fast 25
Prozent und ich weiß sie sagen dann
sofort einen Großteil der Kürzung kommt
ja durch die Nichtverlängerung des
corona-pakets zustande das wäre zeitlich
befristet das sind Argument aber kein
Gutes denn weder ist Corona vorbei noch
sind die Folgen ausgeglichen eine ganze
Generation ist in den letzten Jahren
abgehängt worden und hat als Ansage
mitbekommen eure Interessen spielen für
uns keine Rolle und wenn ihr
selbstvertreten wollt naja dann viel
Glück da ist es ja fast schon
symptomatisch dass die grüne Ministerin
überzieht der FDP-Präsident dann der
jüngsten Abgeordneten Bundestag die
Redezeit um die Hälfte kurz und das beim
Thema Jugendbeteiligung der herzlichen
Glückwunsch
der vorliegende Bericht sagt auf 640
Seiten immer und immer und immer wieder
Kinder und Jugendliche müssen stärker
beteiligt werden und wir können uns auch
neue Zahlen anschauen im kinderreport
des deutschen Kinder- und
jugendhilfswerks von 2022 liest man dann
Überraschung 83 Prozent der Befragten
sagen dass ihre Interessen eher wenig
bis überhaupt gar nicht berücksichtigt
werden 83 Prozent das macht ihr dann
richtig Bock auf Demokratie haben wir ja
gerade gehört trotzdem fordern aber über
drei Viertel der Kids das ist mehr
Kinder und Jugendparlamente gibt die
wollen sich einbringen die wollen mit
bestimmen immer noch deswegen stehen die
heute übrigens auf der Straße und
kämpfen ihre Zukunft und dann muss man
auch echt mal danke sagen zum Glück
machen die das noch ich wünsche auch
viel Erfolg heute dabei
wenn Kinder und Jugendliche lernen
Demokratie nicht darüber dass sie die
Anzahl der Abgeordneten hier auswendig
lernen oder die Namen der minister:innen
die lernen das mit echten
Beteiligungsstrukturen in denen sie
wirklich Entscheidungen treffen können
in der Schule im Jugendclub in
Jugendhilfeeinrichtungen Jugendliche
brauchen Freiräume um sich
auszuprobieren um auch mal zu scheitern
und das passiert vor Ort darum brauchen
wir eine bessere Ausstattung in der
Kinder Jugend- und Sozialarbeit der
Jugendhilfe in Schulen und auch in Kitas
damit dort Beteiligung gelebt werden
kann das braucht Ressourcen und es
braucht Personal und die müssen
langfristig ausgestattet werden
stattdessen gibt es immer wieder
kurzfristige Projekte und ich kann Ihnen
aus eigener Erfahrung sagen ich war mal
Mitarbeiterin bei Demokratie leben
tolles Konzept dann stellen sie einen
Antrag das muss sich der Träger erstmal
leisten können dann haben sie es
vielleicht geschafft dann müssen sie
Zwischenberichte schreiben dann haben
sie eine hochkomplexe Version um das
abzurechnen dann müssen sie das Projekt
bekannt machen dann müssen sie Leute
anwerben und wenn sie dann endlich Zeit
haben mal mit den Kindern und
Jugendlichen zu arbeiten ist das Ding
auch schon wieder vorbei und dann sagen
sie den Leuten hey das können doch die
Kommunen in den regelstr von finanzieren
aber die Kommunen haben ja kein Geld ja
grandios da müsste man doch als
fortschrittskoalition mal rankommen aber
das machen sie nicht ihre Politik
unterscheidet sich im Bereich Kinder und
Jugend von der groko doch nur dass sie
ein paar tiktok-accounts haben und diese
nicht mal gut
vielen Dank Frau Kollege erstmal der
Punkt genaue Landung vielleicht noch mal
kurz zur politischen Bildung das
Präsidium hat folgende Funktion ich
leite die Sitzung die Schriftführerin
zur Linken notiert die Redner und die
Schriftführung zur Rechten notiert die
Redezeiten damit das einigermaßen fair
zugeht es muss einfach dieses Dokument
nicht wer diese Redezeit notiert deshalb
achte ich mal darauf dass es
einigermaßen ausgeglichen ist nächste
Rednerin ist die Kollegin Emilia fester
wenn es 90 gegründet
und Emilia fester hat aus eben diesen
aufgeführten Gründen jetzt nur eine
Minute
Stiftung zeigen dass 65% der jungen
Menschen Interesse an Politik haben noch
mehr haben sich nehmen sich als Teil
einer Generation war die etwas verändern
will die Jugend ist politisch
und gleichzeitig sehen 73 Prozent der 14
bis 24-Jährigen die Anliegen und
Interessen der jungen Generation von der
Politik nicht berücksichtigt heute
versammeln sich vor dieser Tür Frau
reicheneckers angesprochen tausende
junge mündige Menschen für einen
globalen klimastreik sie engagieren sich
und haben doch das Gefühl überhaupt
nicht gehört zu werden die große Politik
ist für meine Generation verbunden mit
Menschen die nicht sprechen wie sie und
die sich nicht mit ihrer Lebenswelt
beschäftigen
zusätzliches Teilhabe immer noch eine
Frage des Geldbeutels und des sozialen
Hintergrunds das kann und darf nicht
sein und deswegen stärken wir als Ampel
freiwillige und bringen die Kinder
Grundsicherung als die größte
jugendgerechte Sozialreform seit langem
auf den Weg liebe Kolleginnen es ist
nämlich auch unsere Verantwortung die
Voraussetzung dafür zu schaffen dass
junge Menschen sich als aktiver Teil
unserer Demokratie verstehen können und
ich habe noch zwei Sätze herr Präsident
deshalb ist es mir egal wie viel Hass
ich im Internet abbekomme solange einen
Großteil der Jugend der jungen Menschen
sich nicht mit Politik identifizieren
kann werde ich nicht damit aufhören zu
versuchen sie zu erreichen und zu
vertreten sie in ihrer Sprache
anzusprechen und Politik erlebbar zu
machen zum Beispiel auf Instagram ich
wünsche Ihnen einen schönes Wochenende
vielen Dank Emilia fester aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen war
neulich Ziel einer sogenannten
Shitstorms der wirklich über viele
Grenzen hinausgegangen ist ja waren dann
noch immer noch immer entscheide ich das
nun die sie dankenswerterweise es wird
auch nicht dazu kommen dass wir es
jemals entscheiden in diesem Haus
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegen sehr
gut dazu und davor das war noch mal ein
Hinweis in Richtung
fdd-fraktion in die zu noch mal zu dem
Thema Redezeiten der von uns heute
debattierte 16 Bericht über die Lage
junger Menschen und die Bestrebungen und
Leistungen der Kinder und Jugendhilfe
von nunmehr zwei Jahren fertiggestellt
wurde und dazu bereits aktuelle Problem
und Konfliktlagen für unser
demokratisches System bewertet wurden
waren die Klimakrise die Pandemie das
fluchtgeschehen und weitere zentrale
Herausforderungen ernsthafte
Schwergewichte für unsere Gesellschaft
das nun noch Krieg Inflation und eine
Energiekrise hinzukommen vergrößert den
Bedarf an politischer und demokratischer
Kompetenz enorm glücklicherweise sind
unsere Jugendlichen bereits heute und
das hörten wir heute mehrfach schon sehr
interessiert an ihrer Umwelt
ehrenamtlich engagiert gut vernetzt
digital mobil pro europäisch kurz auch
Demokraten von morgen dass die Folgen
von Corona und Inflation aber aktuell
auch die Strukturen der Demokratie
Arbeit bedrohen so die Träger der
politischen Bildung in der letzten Woche
besorgt mich denn durch die zweijährige
Zurückhaltung zum Schutz vor Infektion
sind viele Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer den Präsenzveranstaltungen
ferngeblieben dazu kommen jetzt enorme
Kostensteigerung für die Angebote der
politischen Bildung die so für viele
Menschen zu teuer oder für die Anbieter
einfach unwirtschaftlich werden doch der
Bedarf an Austausch und Orientierung
über gesellschaftliche Vorgänge ist
größer denn je die anerkennt anerkannten
Träger der politischen Bildung bitten
Sie liebe Bundesregierung nun um
kurzfristige finanzielle Hilfe und mit
Blick in ihren Koalitionsvertrag und den
Haushaltsentwurf wäre eine solche
Stärkung der etablierten Strukturen in
meinen Augen auch nur folgerichtig denn
fehlende Strukturen lassen sich nur
schwer verstetigen
auch die Schulsozialarbeit ist
Schnittstelle zwischen Schule und
außerschulischen ins nochmal auch die
Schuhe Sozialarbeit ist als
Schnittstelle zwischen Schule und
außerschulischen Institutionen ein
wichtiges Angebot zur
demokratie-förderung das Sozialarbeit
und politische Bildung auch stärker im
corona-programm für Kinder und
Jugendliche berücksichtigt werden müssen
ist daher eine logische Forderung aus
der von ihnen im letzten Sommer
angesetzten Expertenanhörung schade also
dass der Schwerpunkt Bildung trotz
großer Defizite nun völlig im
Nachfolgeprogramm fehlt und da hilft
auch die Ankündigung eines
staatsancenprogramms der
Bundesbildungsministerin wenig wenn
weder das Geld noch ein Konzept
vorliegen ganz im Gegenteil der Aufschub
bis ins Jahr 24 ist bei diesem wichtigen
bildungspolitischen Vorhaben ein
bezeichnendes Statement der neuen
Regierung auf Kosten unserer Kinder und
Jugendlichen
Liebe Bundesregierung gern hätten wir
die Handlungsempfehlungen des Berichts
selbst umgesetzt doch nun sind sie am
Zuger und unsere Kinder Jugendlichen
Eltern und die Institutionen werden sie
an nicht mehr als ihren eigenen Worten
der letzten Jahre messen und bitte
enttäuschen Sie sie nicht vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kolleg deine klaus war
das aus der Unionsfraktion und sie hat
auf das Engagement von Kindern und
Jugendlichen hingewiesen heute ist ein
großer Tag was gerade die jungen Leute
angeht jedenfalls die die sich dafür
aussprechen dass der Klimawandel
aufgehalten werden muss weltweite
Aktionstag von Fridays for future 300
Städten oder in 300 Städten in
Deutschland wird demonstriert auch durch
Berlin zieht ein Zug durchs
Regierungsviertel und hier diskutiert
der Bundestag weiter über den Kinder-
und jugendbericht der Bundesregierung
zum Beispiel mit Felix Döring aus der
SPD-Fraktion will ich das noch mal
unterstreichen was die Frau Ministerin
zu Beginn der Debatte hier gesagt hat
politische Bildung kann nie neutral sein
denn sie ist immer rückekoppelt mit den
Werten der Demokratie Gleichheit
Pluralismus Menschenrechte
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Gewaltenteilung
Minderheitenschutz sind nie verhandelbar
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und der
vorliegende Bericht auch sie sind der
unhintergehbare Kern unserer Demokratie
und deswegen gilt umso mehr politische
Bildung kann niemals neutral sein
zweitens politische Bildung ist auch
keine
gesellschaftspolitische Feuerwehr die
man anrufen kann wenn es brennt sie ist
viel mehr das Material dass die Säulen
unserer Demokratie vor Feuer schützt und
diesen Brandschutz liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen den gibt es nicht zum Nulltarif
folgendes Beispiel wir alle kennen das
aus unseren Wahlkreisen es wird eine
neue Schule gebaut ursprüngliche kosten
10 Millionen dann verzögert sich das
Ganze die Kosten für die Baumaterialien
steigen plötzlich sind wir bei 17 18
Millionen niemand käme ernsthaft auf die
Idee die Schule deshalb nicht fertig zu
bauen und für mich gilt das
gleichermaßen für die Kinder und
Jugendarbeit da müssen wir noch ein
bisschen stärker werden was die
Finanzierung angeht und ich lade alle
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
die daran ein ernsthaftes Interesse
haben herzlich ein mit mir darüber ins
Gespräch zu kommen wie wir in dem
Bereich vielleicht Mittel- und
langfristig eine Dynamisierung der
Finanzierung bekommen drittens
politische Bildung darf nicht im
luftleeren Raum stattfinden Achtung
Negativbeispiel schließen Sie mal die
Augen stellen Sie sich vor Sie stehen in
einem deutschen Klassenraum vor ihnen
27,8 klässlerinnen und Achtklässler es
riecht nach Pubertät und jetzt haben sie
die Aufgabe als Lehrer denen zu erklären
wie bei den Wahlen zum Deutschen
Bundestags zum Deutschen Bundestag
Überhang und Ausgleichsmandate entstehen
mit an sicherheitsgrenzender
Wahrscheinlichkeit werden Sie bei diesem
Unterfangen scheitern weil es mit der
Lebensrealität und den tatsächlichen
Interessen der Kinder- und Jugendlichen
nichts zu tun hat positiv Beispiel ein
Kollege aus meinem Wahlkreis mit dem ich
mich neulich unterhalten hat unterhalten
habe hat mit Anfang 20 in dem
Krankenhaus in dem er seine Ausbildung
gemacht hat eine Betriebsvereinbarung
ausgehandelt die da besagt dass Azubis
in diesem Krankenhaus nicht mehr ohne
Praxisanleitung
arbeiten dürfen und das hat dafür
gesorgt dass auf jeder Station zwei
zusätzliche Stellen im Bereich der
Krankenpflege geschaffen wurden das
Rüstzeug für diese Verhandlungen hat er
durch Bildungsangebote seiner
Gewerkschaft bekommen meine Damen und
Herren das ist
interessengeleitete politische Bildung
und ich bin der festen Überzeugung jeder
Mensch egal ob ein Mitglied des
Deutschen Bundestags oder ein kleines
Kind das gerade erst in die Kita
gekommen ist hat politische Interessen
und deswegen muss es die Aufgabe von
politischer Bildung sein jeden Mensch
dazu zu befähigen für diese Interessen
einzustehen sie auszuhandeln und sie
auch durchzusetzen das sagt übrigens
auch der vorliegende Bericht herzlichen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
Felix döring war das in dieser Debatte
über den Kinder- und jugendbericht der
Bundesregierung und wie es sich für
einen gelernten Lehrer gehört ein
didaktisch aufbereitet dabeitrag hier
geht es weiter mit Paul lehreder aus der
Unionsfraktion und der ist schon der
vorletzte Redner in dieser Aussprache
Liebe Jugendliche auf den Tribünen und
auch draußen an den Bildschirm aus einer
bundesweiten repräsentativen Befragung
des forserinstituts im Frühjahr diesen
Jahres geht hervor dass Politiker im
Internet besonders häufig von Ziel von
Beleidigungen verlorendungen und
Bedrohungen werden gehe davon aus dass
fast alle Abgeordnete hier in diesem
Haus in ihre täglichen Arbeit schon mal
mit unfairem Kommentaren mit
persönlichen Anfeindungen konfrontiert
waren die weiblichen Abgeordneten sind
leider überproportional von Hetze im
Netz betroffen auch ein Blick in die
Kommentarspalten regionaler wie
überregionale Medien haben mit
konstruktiven Meinungsaustausch oft
nichts gemeint angesichts zunehmender
sozialer und politischer Konflikte und
vermehrt zu beobachten der
antidemokratische diskriminierende und
rassistische Einstellungen unserer
Gesellschaft wird der politischen
Bildung und Politik und Öffentlichkeit
völlig zu Recht wieder deutlich mehr
Aufmerksamkeit zu teilen
regional die bundesweit laufen
Förderprogramme und Projekte zur
extremismusprävention und Demokratie
Förderung auch im schulischen Bereich
haben einige Bundesländer in den letzten
Jahren die Bedeutung und Umfang von
Politikunterricht oder demokratiebildung
gestärkt unseren Beitrag leisten gerade
auch wir als Abgeordnete regelmäßig bei
den angerechten Diskussionen mit den
zahlreichen Schulklassen die uns jedes
Jahr hier in Berlin besuchen und ja ich
teile die positive Auffassung der
Kollegin Katja Adler von der FDP das ist
toll ist dass wir wieder Schulklassen
hier in Berlin treffen dürfen das
natürlich der Aufmerksamkeit von
Schulklassen hier in Berlin im Reichstag
oder im Paul-Löbe-Haus eine ganz andere
ist als wenn das theoretisch im
Sozialkunde Unterricht in der Schule
behandelt wird
der Ende 2020 vorgelegte 16 Kinder- und
jugendbericht über den wir heute
sprechen hat den Schwerpunkt auf die
Förderung demokratischer Bildung im
kindes- und Jugendalter gelegt und damit
das Themenfeld umfassend betrachtet auf
über 600 Seiten liefert der Berichte der
jede Erkenntnisse über die vielfältigen
sozialen und digitalen Räume in denen
junge Menschen politische Bildung
erleben und benennt Herausforderungen
mit denen unsere Demokratie konfrontiert
ist das 16 und Kinder und jugendbericht
Fahrrad größere Anerkennung Aufwertung
und Stabilisierung des praxisfeldes
sowie eine breite der Verankerung
politische Bildung für junge Menschen
mit zeitgemäßen und jugendgerechten
Angeboten dabei müssen wir zwingend eine
nachhaltige Strategie im Blick haben die
auch der Langfristigkeit von Lern- und
Bildungsprozessen gerecht wird
hat dankenswerterweise bereits auf die
Freiwilligendienste hingewiesen das
brauche ich nicht nochmal zu wiederholen
unterstreiche alles was er gesagt hat
ich möchte aber auch noch einen Bereich
ansprechen das sind die Beschäftigten im
sozialdienstleistungssektor und gerade
auch die ehrenamtlich geführten Vereine
die ein Praxisbeispiel dafür sind wie
gelebte Demokratie natürlich vorantreten
gelebt ich denke an die
Jugendfeuerwehren ich denke an das
Jugendrotkreuz die Malteser die
Johanniter die Musikkapellen die
Spielmannszüge aber natürlich die
Vielzahl der Sportvereine in denen junge
Menschen demokratische Strukturen
eingelernt bekommen in denen wir
Toleranz zu machen des Anderen eben
entwickeln muss indem man natürlich auch
eine Meinung sich gemeinsam bilden muss
und Herr Präsident
sie leuchten schon wieder auf ich sage
ich muss leider zum Ende kommen wünsche
mir natürlich auch weiterhin eben den
Schritt hier engagierte Jugendliche
jetzt gerade nach Corona wieder in einem
regen vitalen ehrenamtlichen
Vereinsleben in dem Sinne wünsche ich
Ihnen auch ein schönes Wochenende
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege sie wollten
noch Vorbild sein insofern sie wollten
doch Vorbild sein für die jungen
Menschen insofern angemessen
ja noch ein kleines Geplänkel zwischen
Paul lehrräder und Bundestags viel zu
präsident Wolfgang Kubicki und natürlich
geht es auch hier um die Redezeit aber
hat sie ja einigermaßen eingehalten
Ariane Fischer aus der SPD-Fraktion ist
die letzte Rednerin in dieser Debatte
in der Familie den Müll runterbringen
oder hier im politischen Raum mein
Problem müssen die da oben abstellen
oder im Gegensatz dazu die Haltung wer
wenn ich ich und wann wenn ich jetzt
als wichtigen Teil der demokratischen
Stabilisierung empfiehlt der 16 Kinder
und jugendbericht zur Standortfrage der
politischen Bildung in Deutschland eine
verstetigte Finanzierung der politischen
Bildung und der demokratischen
beteiligungs- und beratungsstrukturen
der Bericht fordert uns zudem auf
bereits in der Kita Demokratie wirklich
zu leben nicht nur darüber zu sprechen
und nicht nur darüber zu sprechen und in
diese demokratische Bildung die Familien
strukturell einzubeziehen wo
institutionale realisierte Bildung
wo institutionalisierte Beteiligung als
Alibi oder unwirksam wahrgenommen wird
dort sinkt die Bereitschaft junger
Menschen sich dauerhaft in langfristigen
Strukturen einzubringen und in den und
die Demokratie mitzugestalten nachhaltig
wo stehen wir
galt früher den Generationen ein
aufstiegsversprechen wer sich anstrengt
hat Zukunft erleben Menschen heute
häufig eine Perspektive die von
multiplen Krisen und diffuser oder
konkreter Zukunftsangst geprägt ist
nicht selten löst dies ein Gefühl von
Ohnmacht aus handlungsunfähig
ausgeliefert zu sein unterstützt von
sozialmedialen desinformativ gefütterten
Echokammern kann das dazu führen dass
sie sich gegen andere Menschen abgrenzen
andere herabwürdigen um sich selbst
etwas stärker wichtiger mächtiger zu
fühlen die Studien zeigen aber auch dass
die Wissensvermehrung allein nicht
ausreicht um solche Demokratie
brennenden Einstellungen zu verändern
vielmehr wollen sich gerade junge
Menschen zugehörig und anerkannt fühlen
sie wollen ihre eigenen lebensgeschicke
kontrollieren und sind auf der Suche
nach Teilhabe und Sinnstiftung
fest im Koalitionsvertrag verankert ist
daher der politische Wille der Koalition
nachhaltige demokratie-förderung in die
Regelfinanzierung zu überführen der
Begriff Demokratie fördergesetz weckt
aber bei den zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen in Deutschland bei den 29
Millionen Menschen engagiert sind und im
Ehrenamt engagiert sind sehr sehr hohe
Erwartungen denn sie bieten den
Erfahrungsraum dass es sich lohnt sich
für die Gemeinschaft einzusetzen
sie sind vor Ort sichtbar und spürbar
kann man hier das Gemeinwesen
mitgestalten und persönlich verändern
auch dort prägt sich das demokratische
erleben und genau das ist letztlich
neben der institutionellen politischen
Bildung die wirksamste Prävention gegen
Ohnmacht Hass Extremismus und Gewalt
Selbstwirksamkeit im eigenen Tun erleben
ich bringe mich ein das ändert etwas und
deswegen werden wir mit der nationalen
ehrenamtsstrategie in der Folge dieses
gesamte Feld verstetigt weiterentwickeln
und der Demokratie weiterhin den großen
Raum bieten für junge Menschen sich zu
erfahren
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Marianne
Fischer war das aus der SPD-Fraktion und
damit ist die Aussprache beendet zum
Kinder- und jugendbericht der bundesre